Wow that's a great goal I get to make
the lot in training oh that's the
classic Wow Oh
so the dance is good and then D please
don't take penalties no way this is a
good free kick everything's wrong right
it probably doesn't even look at the
ball now I've seen I've seen this before
I think it's actually zinchenko isn't it
Wow
that's a great goal that's a grateful
and he hits the ball and the balls
coming down
that's not easier so yeah great
technique that's a good neck yeah I kind
of make Mindy a lot but it doesn't let
me put the videos on Instagram yeah the
only thing the defender can do is go
back and try to get the ball but it
looks kind of disappointed doesn't it
I would be as well I would be as well to
be honest I get smacked a lot in
training and it's it's always little if
it's in a mini game for me doesn't
matter if I get Meg by a friend well I
don't like it so it hurts these kind of
things are it does everything perfect
puts the goalkeeper on the ground then
misses it
oh I'd like to see done the chip that
that's a great goal ah how old was he
five years five years old doing that Wow
yes future oh that's a classic the goal
is going in for sure yeah that's the
classic the goalkeeper is celebrating in
the ball goes in really trust least
who'd I trust least benjamin netanyahu
didn't trust me now
and then the please don't take penalties
no way
Wow that's another great bowler and he's
very young number 10
that's a David Beckham gola coming in
sides far post and the dancer the dance
is good I don't know how to do that I've
tried it but I don't know how to do it
well normally you eat the ball like that
and he goes and he hits it the opposite
way and the ball makes the opposite
movement so my top free is in the first
place
it's the Meg the one either's backwards
it's always humiliating for the defender
in your kind you kind of feel good when
you did the second one there has to be
the last freaking the one that it hits
really hard and does the movement and
top one is the play from the little kid
it goes past a few players and then
chips the ball on this on the far post
so that's my favorite one can Bernardo
Silva and that was right my skills
[Music]
you